einmal durchatmen dann beginnt für lee
wieder das rennen gegen die zeit ein
wagen voller pakete seine deadline ist
21 uhr danach drohen sogar strafen
hallo hier ist der lieferant
ist das für uns haben sie bitte nicht
runter nicht runter kommen
südkorea steckt mitten in der vierten
welle die menschen wollen kontakte
vermeiden und bestellen so viel wie nie
zuvor
die last liegt auf schultern von
lieferanten bieli keine pausen
überstunden bis zur erschöpfung
[Musik]
der koreaner arbeiten hart sehr hart
aber jetzt wo immer mehr menschen
sterben wird die frage lauter warum das
passiert und wir beginnen zu begreifen
dass die todesursache häufig
überarbeitung ist
trotzdem konkurrieren die großen
logistikunternehmen mit immer kürzeren
lieferzeiten um aufträge wer da nicht
mitzieht ist raus aus dem geschäft
komm schon wir haben keine zeit
sie bräuchte mindestens eine weitere
stunde um alle pakete abzugeben aber
seit sich die todesfälle bei paket
lieferanten häufen sind zustellungen
nach neun uhr abends verboten die firmen
stehen unter druck arbeitsbedingungen zu
verbessern und lee erhält jetzt jeden
abend eine automatisierte nachricht wenn
er trotzdem weitermacht geschieht das
auf eigene verantwortung das ist doch
klar dass die firma diese nachricht nur
schickt um sich abzusichern was soll ich
denn machen
ich habe noch 66 pakete im auge
ein teufelskreis alles was er heute
nicht schafft verlängert den nächsten
arbeitstag und für verspätete
lebensmittel verlangt ließ arbeitgeber
sogar eine entschädigung
die firma verlangt von uns dann einen
ausgleich im wert der bestellung wenn
die lebensmittel 40 euro wert sind muss
sich 40 euro strafe zahlen
nach 16 stunden macht lief am abend
150 euro hat er heute verdient etwa
einen euro pro paket sechs tage die
woche ist das sein leben für ihn eine
frage des überlebens
die ehe ist zerbrochen wenigstens den
töchtern will er eine zukunft bieten
[Musik]
meine kinder haben nichts zu essen wenn
ich nicht genug aber also nehme ich das
alles in kauf sie nicht zu sehen hart zu
arbeiten und geld zu verdienen
südkorea hat es mit harter arbeit zu
wohlstand gebracht mit den längsten
arbeitstagen aller industriestaaten aber
die paket lieferanten sind nicht mehr
bereit diesen preis zu bezahlen
6500 arbeiter aus dem ganzen land sind
in die hauptstadt seoul gekommen und
bereits versprochenen reformen
einzufordern lasst uns gemeinsam kämpfen
haben könnt ihr hier
das abkommen einzufordern noch
versprochene datum ist längst
verstrichen
tod durch überarbeitung ist in südkorea
so weit verbreitet dass es sogar einen
eigenen begriff dafür gibt kva rosa
auch lee ist nach soll gereist auch
erkannte kollegen die durch den
arbeitsstress kollabiert sind
die eltern von chandhok tun mussten
lange dafür kämpfen bis der tod ihres
sohnes als arbeitsunfall anerkannt wurde
er hatte 18 monate am stück in
nachtschichten gearbeitet als er sich
frisch machen wollte und plötzlich sein
herz versagte
[Musik]
mein mann hat ihn kniend und von über
gebeugten der dusche gefunden
seine hände hat er um seine boos
geschlungen ich frage mich die ganze
zeit warum haben wir ihn nicht früher
gefunden
er war 27 jahre alt im verpackungs
zentrum von coop an dem südkoreanischen
amazon hatte die adoption im akkord
bestellungen für den versand vorbereitet
mit echtzeitüberwachung und der
sogenannten rocket delivery hatte scoop
an zum schnellsten lieferdienste im
ganzen land geschafft
die pandemie hat seine arbeit noch viel
anstrengender gemacht
wenn ich gewusst hätte was für eine art
von unternehmen die kupon ist dann hätte
ich ihm die arbeit dort verboten
wenn ich gesehen hätte wie viel gewicht
er verloren hat dann hätte ich alles
getan um ihn zu stoppen
ein lkw mit der aufschrift kupon hat
meinen sohn getötet damit sind die
eltern monate lang durch das land
gefahren sie wollten arbeiter und
unternehmen wachrütteln um anderen
familien ihr leid zu ersparen
erst nach einem halben jahr erreicht sie
der offizielle brief todesursache
überarbeitung
ich wünschte ich könnte dir folgen mein
sohn dr
es tut mir so leid
ich hätte dich viel öfter in den arm
nehmen sollen
auch lee hat seine töchter lange nicht
mehr in den armen gehalten endlich mal
wieder ein freier tag und zeit sie
anzurufen vor der pandemie hat er sie
zumindest regelmäßig besucht seit corona
hat er angst sie an zu stecken könnt ihr
mich sehen
die auch für mich
ich möchte sehen wie groß der geworden
bist
[Musik]
nur für sie nimmt er dieses leben in
kauf aber seine töchter sieht er dadurch
immer seltener
[Musik]